e
okay we're going to get started now the
right okay welcome welcome everyone uh
my name is John janigian I'm the chair
of ways and means and uh looks like
we've got a pretty good attendance we
might be missing a couple of people but
um I think we should get started um so I
want to First just uh welcome you to the
ways and means uh committee uh some of
you obviously are returning members some
of you are brand new uh some of you have
been elected for the first time and some
of you are returning um to the
legislature so um
probably the best thing to start off
with is go around the room and have each
person introduce themselves um and I
guess uh mention if this is your first
term or not if not what other committees
uh have you been on um and um how long
you've been a state rep if you've been
here before and then what's your what's
your background uh and uh your work
background so forth so um I'll I'll
let's see should I start off I guess
I'll start off and then we'll go one way
and then the other um as I said my name
is John janigian this is my fif starting
my fifth term uh in the house um I was
on the um Public Works and highways
committee for the first four years and
I've been on ways and means since I
became uh
chairman um beginning of uh last year
and um halfway halfway through that term
and uh now starting this term it'll be a
complete term um
and my background is uh for the first 25
years of my working life I was a uh
started off as a computer programmer um
I have a degree in computer science
master's degree in computer science a
bachelor's in chemistry uh the chemistry
part I've never never really used um and
was in the computer field for 25 years
after that it made a complete career
change um I'm now a real estate uh
broker part-time um manage some
properties and uh also a State Rep
so that's it we'll move to the left here
to um clerk thank you Mr chairman I'm
Bill M this is my fourth term in the uh
legislature uh all on ways and means I
took a six-year sabatical and now I'm
back in the uh in office my background
is as a businessman I ran a high-tech
company of about 100
people um have degrees in engineering
and
business and I live in uh Nashville New
Hampshire for the last 20 years I used
to have an apple orchard out in uh
Pelham and that was a fun project for a
back thank you Bill I'm Bill Bolton uh
this is my second term um uh last one
was um you know Ways and Means in this
one as well and I'm a 30-year retired
state employee working for public health
generally and then I became the uh State
registar and the director of division of
Vital Records and I then became uh
implementation manager from some
software that every um State and
territory needed for Vital record
sharing so my focus was on public health
and uh now I'm an executive director of
Transport Central it's a small nonprofit
and we provide transportation to elderly
and disabled up in the Plymouth area
and I'm also very um active in our
municipality I've held four terms on the
select board um as chair and vice chair
and I'm finally stepping down from that
um and that's pretty much
it thank you
Fred good morning thank you Mr chairman
I'm Fred ducet I'm starting my sixth
term here in the house uh let's see I
started my career in the United States
Navy subse quent to that I uh spent 25
years as a firefighter paramedic in
Salem I'm since retired a long time ago
and I've spent the rest of my time being
a public servant up here and I very much
look forward to this committee doing
what it's done over many years is
working
collaboratively got a task ahead of us
and we need to work together to get
things done most specifically uh
estimates as as soon as we can screw
together but uh I look forward to
working with you all thank you
representative
Ford hello thank you chairman um I'm
Mary Ford I'm a career educator I've
been a teacher a state director of
special ed and for the last um 30 years
I have been uh preparing teachers and so
I have developed programs implemented
programs evaluated
programs um all with an eye on creating
high quality credit efficient affordable
programs that make money so um um I'm
glad to be here and I look forward to
working with the committee thank you
representative
TIY I'm Jim Tierney uh Coos one this is
my second term I'm 15 and a half year
veteran of the US Air Force uh retail
and then came FEMA for 10 years and
other than that I've been retired I'm on
the board of Selectmen finishing up my
10th year on that in uh North umberland
again
okay representative Brier yeah uh I'm
I'm Scott Brier I'm from Northwood uh
represented Rockingham district one this
I'm a freshman it's my first uh term as
a State Rep um M uh I have a bachelor's
degree in accounting I also have a MBA
um I've wor 35 and A2 years retired from
uh Department of Safety um in the
capacity I ran the road toll Bureau uh
which is basically the gas
tax um I also did 13 years with the uh
office of legislative budget assistant I
was uh when I left there I was an audit
manager before I went over to
safety uh I was uh On The Board of
Trustees for the international fuel tax
agreement for probably around uh 12
years uh during that time I was the
president of that for two years for the
US and Canada provinces and states and
also was very active in the uh
Federation of tax administrations with a
concentration in field
tax and locally uh I was a selectman for
21 years I'm currently on the school
board and I'm also a police commissioner
in the town of
northw thank
op um I'm Thomas Opel repes representing
Kanan Dorchester and orange Grafton 9 um
this is my first term as a state
representative but what feels like a
million years ago in the late 70s and
80s I was actually a reporter first for
the national Telegraph and then for UPI
covering this body um along with the
other chamber um I uh have spent most of
my career as a communications consultant
although representative ducet I had the
great privilege and honor of serving as
Chief of Staff to the Secretary of the
Navy for eight years and I have a a son
who's a second class petty officer so go
Navy beat
Army thank you representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman um my name
is Mary Murphy I Am uh the the new State
Rep is my first term for Hillsboro 27
which is Deering in Francis town uh most
recently um I have started up a software
company with emergency medicine
physician for an AI assisted uh search
engine that's going to expose the
self-pay cash price for every procedure
uh that patients might need uh previous
to that I owned a very successful it was
uh I built the largest independent
wealth management firm in the state and
sold it two years ago to one of my
employees and then prior to that I was a
Fortune 500 senior executive for IBM uh
heading up their Telco and internet
service Division and so I'm on the broad
Broadband Committee in Francis town for
that reason so that's the extent of my
my public service thank you thank you
representative Spar uh thank you
chairman and am I pronouncing that
properly yes Spar thank you uh my
background I I left school I got into
the insurance and investment sales world
for about seven years and then I went
into real estate brokerage and I was in
the uh uh with the largest independent
broker in the country for about 20 years
and uh worked at some executive levels
with them I left the business about 7
years ago and produced and wrote a
environmental documentary which won a
whole bunch of awards was on PBS and uh
now I'm an executive director of a
environmental
nonprofit thank you representative ORS
yeah thank you Mr chair so I'm
representative s ORS my second term
first term was on ways and
means uh I join the Army right out of
high school so I'm going to cut the Navy
guys a break because my son was in the
Navy uh but our whole family has served
uh I am an accountant an auditor a
controller a VP of Finance own two
businesses photography studio had a do
com with Johnson and Johnson Healthcare
years ago and uh since I retired which
has been a long time from Bae I worked
uh as a part-time teacher and I taught
accounting at a community college and
now I have a real job here so thank you
very much
thank you representative shamberg uh my
name is Tom shamberg I represent marac 6
the towns of Wilmont and Sutton this is
my fifth term here on ways and means and
I got here because of my 30 years of
teaching K through 12 fit health and
English and I could roll out 10 balls
and get 10 balls back and that numbers
I'm I'm high in numbers here all right
uh
I have uh served as uh four terms now as
a select men of the town of wilmet three
terms on the municipal budget committee
and uh served as a mayor of my community
in Ohio for 14 and a half years before I
came to New Hampshire and got a law
degree and then for those of you that
have a hard time pronouncing chairman
jian's name mine is shamberg like a ham
an iceberg and take drink and you'll say
it just right thank
you thank you representative elberger
good morning to everyone uh and if
you're having trouble with Tom's name
elberger uh when I was a kid the the
Goof on it was hamburger but I knew I
became an adult when the Goof on it was
limberger so uh it's it's just elberger
as easily as you can uh spell it uh I
have a an undergraduate degree in
sociology with a minor in Psych Master's
in in counseling and Personnel Services
I spent a fair amount of my uh career
working in addiction treatment including
running drunk driving programs try that
for fun if you want it sometime
um I
uh am a second generation American uh
all four of my grandparents came to this
country around 1900 fleeing
anti-Semitism um in terms of government
work I spent six years on the school
board in Lexington Massachusetts 12
years as an elected member of town
meeting in Lexington and then six more
years an elected member of the Arlington
town meeting uh my husband and I run a
weekly Radio Show in NASA called Susan
and Jim talked NASA we were trying to
come up with a clever title and I guess
we did uh we have guests in talking
about things ranging from politics to
provence of antique cars which was a
really fun show uh and this is my second
term as a legisl uh legislator and
second term on ways and
means thank you representative Malloy
thank you Mr chairman my name is Dennis
Malloy I live in Greenland and I
represent Greenland and Ry uh here in uh
the state house I have been on this
committee now for five terms
and I've been in the house for six terms
my first uh term I was serving in
barington we moved to Greenland and on
that during that term I was on Municipal
and County
government the uh I have a master's
degree in journalism and uh went into
marketing right out of uh college and
I've I spent my career running a radio
station and uh raising money for iow
public television and New Hampshire
public television it's my background
retired from that 10 12 years ago and
then have been doing this ever since I
am a trustee of trust funds in Greenland
I'm on a number of various boards and
other
commissions uh for uh New
Hampshire and uh I look forward to uh
serving again thank you very much thank
you represent
Aly thank you
um I this is my 15th term um the first
term uh was the first term that Ways and
Means was folded into
finance and um I wanted to be on finance
and I
uh um got told that I couldn't be
because I was a freshman so um I went to
election law because I thought I could
do something about election law reform
and um my second term I got on finance
and I was part of the group that first
uh put together the the education
funding uh solution there were 10 of us
trapped in a room for
six six weeks 6 and a half hours a day I
mean six and no six and a half days a
week sorry
um I came from um um 25 years of
overseas work in uh nonprofits one of
them uh two of them the international
agricultural research
institutes I um got a PhD in order to be
able to do what I wanted to do which was
work with uh small
farmers and and uh redo the The Boro
agriculture Revolution to something that
would work outside of flat Fields uh
and on I worked
in I spent six years in Brazil five
years in Cameroon 3 years in Madagascar
and at that point I could not uh breathe
anymore the air in the cities of third
world countries and I had to retire I
developed a severe form of asthma and I
came home and was trying to figure out
what to do when uh I was asked if I
would run for State
Rep uh my first year in
Lebanon and um it was nominal I was
supposed to lose um the Republicans had
all of the seats in Lebanon um
and I won and and then I went back to
Madagascar to train some somebody but uh
so I missed orientation but I've been on
ways and means itself since my third
term and we have we learned very quickly
to
collaborate uh in our committee once it
was
reformed um because we all have
different different skills and different
EXP experiences that help to understand
what our economy is in this state and
the influences that come on it from
outside and we need to share them so
um I was I've been chair four times um
the first time was two terms of the the
Great
Recession so um I was one of the people
that
with Governor Lynch helped us through
the Great
Recession and um
I've here here
again great thank you representative
ulery my name's Jordan oler this is uh
only my 11th term she's got me beat and
I've known her for almost as
long I came over from um uh criminal
justice uh in my first year after the
death of uh one of the members over
there which made an unbalance committee
and I've stayed here since in addition
I've uh worked uh part-time on uh
Judiciary and uh a couple of uh uh small
visits over to uh
transportation in the real world I
started off doing ambulance driver work
became one of the first nationally
registered amts then became one of the
first nationally registered
paramedics um helped Usher that uh
medical Advance into the state of uh New
Hampshire uh the former Chief of
conquered and the former director of
Emergency Services was uh my
classmate
um after that I became an insurance
fraud
investigator and that was fun uh
particularly when I got a couple of
attorneys disbarred for cheating
that was
fun you're collecting workers comp you
go in for your medical examination on
the way out you take your collar off you
take your Walker off and put it in the
trunk and give it to you and give the
collar to your attorney while you
opening the trunk
um that kind of
activities uh something that when people
say there isn't fraud in Insurance there
is uh it's there a lot I've served on
ways and means uh and helped to come up
with some budgets either with uh Norm
major or John Janan or Susan Aly as uh
uh
chair as this year is showing normally
we're within 95% of accuracy when we
compile our estimated budgets this year
may be an
outlier uh there's going to be some hard
decisions to make uh
hard decisions to make we're have to
take that into
consideration thank you thank you and
representative
sodi hi my name is julus soti this is my
uh third term second time on Ways and
Means first time I was on
education uh let's see my um educational
background is I have a degree in uh
philosophy and history and I've worked
in construction I was a probation
officer for a while and finally a real
estate investor and I own and manage my
own real estate and I'm ready to get
busy here on wages and means excellent
thank you well we've got a lot of sounds
like we have a lot of great experience
on this committee and uh I welcome all
of you and I'm glad we're all going to
be able to work
together um let's see so what I want to
do now is
um pretty much just talk about and this
will probably benefit the new members
the most you know what how do how do
things work and so forth um it'll be a
review for those of you who have been
here before and I'm I'm sure Susan and
Jordan can uh can jump in at times and
and give more uh more feedback both of
them having many years uh on this
committee um but basically the the main
role of this committee is is basically
um twofold um Revenue generating Revenue
estimates um that finance will then use
to determine how much can the state
spend over the next bium and uh we will
spend a good part of our
next probably five to six weeks figuring
out what do we think the revenues are
going to be coming into the state over
the next year and over the next actually
two years and uh there will be updates
from time to time but we've got to have
our best guesstimate um due by I believe
it's around February 15th
um we may have some I know Finance uh
the chair of Finance uh would like to
know something sooner um and uh because
they have to they're the ones that
figure out how to spend the money we the
ones that say how much they have to
spend so it's it's an important job that
obviously we need to take seriously and
uh figure out so what we'll be doing is
we'll be hearing from uh committees like
well actually next uh next week we'll be
me meeting on the 13th and the 14th
primarily to hear from different state
organizations like Department of Revenue
um and and the different departments as
to not necessarily what they're
expecting for money yet but so that
people understand what is it they do and
for example with Dr there's um they'll
go over the Myriad of taxes that they
create uh collect and what are they and
when they're collected and so forth next
time we have to use Dr as an example
next time we have them back it'll be to
say what are your what does it look like
what uh how have we been hitting
expectations have we been missing
expectations if so by how much and what
do you see happening um in the coming uh
year and and by any them uh the other
important thing that we do obviously is
is uh look at the bills that come to our
committee and I looked last night so far
we have five bills in the committee I
expect a lot more uh will come in uh so
any bills dealing with
um tax uh related uh issues like
increase of tax decrease of tax remove
ATT tax uh fee related anything that's
affecting the the money coming into the
state is a bill that presumably would
come here first we will get a couple of
second committee bills where it's been
uh you know the the
policy uh I'll give you an example
um one that one that obviously comes to
mind is the um is marijuana bills
policy-wise they go to um wherever they
go to probably Health and Human Services
I guess or or one of those committees
first um and then if it passes out of
that committee it passes out of the
house it could come to us because maybe
there's some sort of expenditure in it
or tax or something um or not
expenditure I should say tax or fee um
then it would come to our committee to
discuss um we don't have that many
second committee bills most of them will
be first committee
bills um any any questions uh I don't
want to go through this whole thing and
not have qu if people have questions
feel free to raise your hand I'll call
on you um a lot of you for the new
people the the I think you already have
a sense of how it works but if you have
a question you would raise your hand
I once I recognize you you can speak um
if you have a follow-up question you
would I mean this this is a little less
formal right now because it's kind of an
orientation but typically once we get
into our regular meetings uh if you have
a follow-up question you'd have to be
recognized for the follow-up question as
well um but anyways any questions so far
on what I've what I've
covered okay good glad everything's
Crystal Clear um but don't hesitate if
uh you have any questions so those are
the main main goals uh of of this
committee um for those of you uh who
don't know if you go on to the State
website
um well I guess you can go on the State
website and navigate yourself into the
legislature into the house and
specifically you can look at committees
and then go to Ways and Means and see
so when we do work on on
bills um
basically we will start with the fir the
first step will be to have I'll schedule
public hearings on on bills and public
hearings at the public hearings we'll
have typically the public can will come
and if somebody wants to speak we have
things called pink cards there'll be
pink cards that people fill out with
their name and um you know how long
they're going to speak whether they're
for or against the bill and then we'll
hear from them they'll typically sit in
this seat uh directly in in front of me
um and um we after they give their
initial testimony we as a committee can
ask them questions and you know
obviously I'll I'll recognize you raise
your hand I'll recognize you you can ask
a question um one thing that we don't do
that I notice happens at the federal
level is we don't put people on the hot
seat and Grill them and them how
terrible they are
and and uh the uh the decorum uh in the
house and in the house committees is to
treat uh people with respect if you
totally disagree with a person you don't
you don't express that um our main thing
is to understand why are they for or
against the bill you know so we're
questioning them we're hearing their
answers um we can certainly ask a
followup if we don't understand their
answer but we don't put them on the hot
seat and tell them how they're wrong or
or you know in that regard
um typically uh some bills there there
may be they may just be introduced there
may be one speaker and and they're done
uh other bills that are more
controversial um there may be situations
where we have 15 people that want to
speak and
um typically you know again on the pink
card they have to put down how long they
think they're going to speak and I'll
have those pin cards before I call on
people so I'll be able to say okay this
person wants to speak for 2 minutes okay
they're four minutes in and it doesn't
look like they're going to end you know
I'll I'll most likely interrupt them and
say okay you put two minutes can you
please finish up um and uh you know I
guess the the only other case would be
people are sticking to their time frames
but then we have more people that want
to speak I might have to put a time
limit on usually try not to do that
because we want to hear what people have
to say um if
if the person is repeating themselves or
questions being asked seem like
repetitive and we're getting the same
answers you know I may say okay I think
you know we have the answer to that um
and so forth yes representative ORS
thank you Mr chair so my question is are
we going to pre-amp the pink cards with
a three minute time
stamp that was a joke
okay well in other words it may be that
may have been a joke but if no we don't
pre-amp anything however if there's tons
and tons of pink cards I may say please
limit and then typically as we get let's
say it's one of those situations where
there's a whole bunch of speakers and I
get getting you know halfway through
twoth thirds of the way through and
somebody's going to talk for 10 minutes
I may say okay could further could
future speakers please avoid talking
about the same things that have already
been talked about please you know add on
to what you've had so that we keep uh
people awake and um get through it
so Susan did you have something you want
to say are you going to talk about when
the lobbyists and the department people
can
speak
um possibly but uh thank you for
bringing that up I did write an outline
for myself but it's very that's why it's
very easy to to miss something um
typically what we do is we have
um I guess you can correct me if I'm
wrong but typically um if I have sen
state senators and state reps here we
typically after the bill is introduced
we'll typically hear from uh state
senators first um because they typically
have many things going on um also try to
hear from State reps who are on other
committees because they're probably here
I'm trying to get back to their
committee so we'll hear from them uh
then we'll hear from the public did you
have anything to is that um and the
Departments and the left the Departments
would probably be the
Departments yeah the Departments would
be
last is that what you were
thinking
unless the department knows a lot more
about the bill anybody else there sure
yeah yeah if it's something where the
department is is you know we I know that
or people have questions we want to get
the Department into uh answering that
before we have people going on so that
we can build on those uh
answers okay yes represent so there's
essentially no set time frame or
structure for the questionings other
than that the normally the Senators are
first and followed by uh the lobbyist in
public
well State reps yeah W we're
insignificant
um the the other question is you've got
a blue sheet down at the end in pink
cards and if anyone uh asks you if they
have to talk no they can sign the blue
sheet and they're just then it's just
Pro or Con on the bill with no place for
uh except for this there's this either
Pro or Con on that you can also go
online and uh if anyone asks for the
Freshman there's a place online where
you can make some comments that
eventually gets into the record it gets
into the record not necessarily read
into uh the committee meeting um and
depending upon what we do tomorrow that
may change too there may be some changes
there may not be probably won't be but
public you're thinking public hearing
yeah I'm thinking public hearing Bill 44
but that you know that's whatever that
yeah I mean currently for those of you
who aren't up on this every bill has a
public hearing no matter whether we
think it's a crazy bill or not or it's
every Bill uh gets a public hearing uh
representa ol is referring to um a rule
change that we'll be voting on tomorrow
that um basically says that if um I may
not have this complete but basically I
think you a committee can um not would
would have the ability not to hold a
public hearing if is it three quarters
three quarters of the committee uh say
okay we don't hear so I mean we'll see
what happens with that but that's the
only caveat to what we're saying about
public
hearings
yes U one other thing for the new
members these little thingies that we
have in front of us if you haven't used
them before it's pressed to
talk and press to listen because there's
a speaker in here as well as a
microphone you should have heard the
difference in
voice um so if the red light's on you're
talking the red light's off you're
listening all right see and keep the
microphone close to your face not down
the edge of the thing but because
they're directional mics so you want to
talk into the microphone if you want to
be heard and this uh committee meeting
and matter of fact all of them now
aren't they being recorded are being
recorded yeah I I don't know you're on
video right now quite
possibly you should always assume the
the mic is
open no no you're only supposed to say
that to our
[Laughter]
okay um anything any
questions okay um so th those are the
public hearings um I will open um yeah I
don't have my G my gav's over there but
typically I'll have a gavel um I will
hit the gavel open the public hearing
when it's over I'll close the public
hearing um the only other time I guess I
would use a gavel in between that would
be if um we needed to recess for some
reason uh or if uh something was out of
control um which I haven't seen happen
in a in a long time so hopefully we we
can continue that way um okay so bills
go through basically three uh segments
first the the public hearing we just
talked about that next is the um work
session although it doesn't have to go
through a work session technically it
could go right to an executive session
typically I try to put every Bill
through a work session unless it's it's
a very simple Bill we're kind of all on
board uh both parties are pretty much
all on board on what it is we may go
directly to an exec session and uh
and and vote on it but but first let me
cover work sessions so work sessions
basically are an opportunity to talk
about the bill okay by now we've heard
we've heard the uh we've gone through
the public um um the public hearings um
we've got information we discuss it
amongst ourselves and um somebody may
bring an amendment to to the bill saying
you know I I brought an amendment uh
here's what I think and you know we can
discuss that um
um once I once I feel like okay we've
pretty much exhausted uh that discussion
we'll end the the work session on that
bill and um we can either go on to
another work session on another bill or
we could go on to an executive session
on that bill typically if the bill was
somewhat complicated or there's
follow-up needed or somebody's going to
get an amendment or something typically
obviously we would not do an exec
session we not vote on it we' I'd say
okay we'll we'll push this off for a
couple of weeks while or a week while we
gather information and we'll have an
exec session on it at that
time uh and then lastly is the uh bill
then can go through an exec session
where typically somebody will make a
motion they make a motion um to itl uh
the bill let's say which would be
inexpedient to legislate which is
basically saying we as a committee are
going to recommend to the Full House
that they kill this bill if it goes itl
once it has a second then we discuss it
once discussion is done I can call for a
vote
um and um go you know and go from there
the clerk would call the role um the
role starts with uh the vice chair is
called first to answer how they would
vote um since the Republicans have a
majority the Republicans would then uh
we go through the list each would vote
then we go to the
um ranking Democrat start first yeah so
the ranking Democrat would start first
and then we go down the line of
Democrats and then the chair who's me
obviously would vote
last
um let's see so it could be itl and
experential legislate um it could be um
that o OTP ought to pass is the
terminology we use if we want to pass a
bill um we could
um I guess if we defer a bill we don't
make yeah or you right you could have an
not to pass with an amendment uh in
which case you need to pass the
amendment first or you need to vote not
pass you need to vote on the amendment
first and then then we'd vote on the
underlying Bill sometimes there's more
than one Amendment and we'd have to um
you know handle each Amendment first and
then and then the
bill any Jordan or or anyone else have
any anything to add to that or any
questions yes representative om yes as
the clerk I believe the chairman post
you anyone have any questions and you'll
get to know you I mean those of you who
are new will get those of you who have
been on other committees I think the
process should be pretty similar um and
those of you who are new will get it
pretty quickly I think as to what what
happens it's not not a complicated
process it's more just understanding how
it goes
together okay what else do we have
[Music]
yes no um everyone knows who yes that
might not be a bad idea um yes I'd like
to introduce our researcher Jennifer for
four she's uh sitting in the corner over
there with laptop she's a
researcher um she's invaluable to us uh
on a lot of um on well not a lot on on
bills and uh also sometimes there's just
questions on uh maybe something you know
have we voted on this before historical
just information about
background um did you want to add
history of certain issue um been with
admin and if I don't know the answer
I'll tell you that I don't know but I'll
thank you
yes
yes yeah maybe we should have yeah you
administrative and here she is this is
Karen kwaki and um
she she is another invaluable resource
um she helps out um tremendously and
you're you're also helping what three or
four other committees I
Karen we kind of went through this
quicker than I thought uh but um I've
I'll just talk about our next meetings
and then at 11:30 I have food uh being
delivered and so um we uh our agenda for
today today is
um 11 well 11:30 roughly 11:30 lunch
will be served depending on
uh when they arrive and then at 1
o'clock we're going to hear from the um
New Hampshire Society of certified
public accountants um we obviously do a
lot with taxes in this committee and so
hearing from them is uh is a valuable
resource um I that's um slated for about
an hour so we should be done by 2 o' uh
for those of you trying to plan your
afternoon
um so we will um so I'll just I'm going
to talk about the next two meetings
briefly and uh so as you probably know
and I assume those of you who are new
you know that you can see the calendars
online uh to know what's what's coming
up and so forth um so we have meetings
scheduled now on the 13th and 14th
Monday and Tuesday of next week um both
of those start at 9:00 which is an
earlier start than I normally start most
of the time most of our meetings will
start at
10:00 um and the reason I'm starting at
9: is because we have a lot to get
through and I want to finish by uh 3
3:30 time frame um and not uh because
people who are on boards in their
hometowns you know whether it's
selectman or planning board or whatever
it is uh typically we we try to you know
keep that keep that in mind um as well
as just other other things that uh need
to be done in your personal life so um
so we will start at 9:00 both those days
and as I said most times it'll be 10:00
U but it'll be noticed in the calendar
um just for planning purposes I believe
I don't have it scheduled yet but most
likely we'll meet uh the following
week um okay we already know about
Monday the 13th Tuesday the 14th the
following week uh the the 20th is Martin
Luther King Day um we will not meet on
that day typically this this committee
will meet on Mondays and Tuesdays in
general um we share this room for those
of you who are new um before covid that
that you see the sliding um or I should
call it accordion door used to be closed
all the time and each committee would be
you know like Ways and Means would you
be just in this side and criminal
justice uh would be on the other side
for example
uh but since Co and we opened up the
room to create more space we've kept it
that way ever since so we share this
double room with criminal justice um and
I've talked to uh uh representative
Terry Roy we're going to continue what
we did last year which was Ways and
Means will take Mondays and Tuesdays
criminal justice will take Wednesday
Thursdays and
Fridays um but we'll share Wednesdays
from time to time so the week of the
20th is one of those times um I've
already talked to him and communicated
with him so plan on Tuesday the
21st and Wednesday the 22nd that will
have meetings
um and I'm not sure what you know the
the that meetings those meetings will be
yet because it's could be a mix of
hearing from agencies because as I said
one of our jobs is to do Revenue
estimates and I may start a couple of
public hearings on um the bills that we
have so which day I'm going to do that
and so forth I don't know but but I
would say we need both of those days um
I'll probably start the start time and
those probably will be 10 o'clock
um unless there's some issue with uh
somebody presenting a bill but I
typically try to stay away from 9:00 the
earliest it would probably be as 9:30
but uh you'll see the times come out of
the calendar um or I I may even know by
by you know let's say the 13th or 14th
when we meet and can announce it then as
well but definitely reserve the 21st and
the
22nd as well
so yes represent Al me
yeah I'd like
to to talk tell my
caucus on
that we are going to have to we are not
finishing until 2 most of us are going
to take an hour to get back home and we
have a
caucus a general caucus starting at
3: so we H today today okay that's right
so so we can't um meet informally to
talk about what we've just been
listening to and other questions
until I am
not um sure when this week is pretty
messy
unless we uh got together somehow on
Friday we're going to have to wait until
next week and stay
after the the meetings on T Monday
Tuesday Monday or
Tuesday we can discuss it online but on
I presume the Republicans also will be
integrating in a informal caucus
okay I think that's all that's all I
really have right now does anyone have
any
questions yes thank you Mr chair so you
said we want to have our results ready
for the finance committees by February
15th by February 15th okay now he I know
that I'm going to get pushed to give
some preliminaries sooner but we won't
publicize anything until that time frame
okay I I just wanted to check because
it's a Saturday so I just thought I'd I
mean technically we're
proba yeah I'm I'm not sure how that
works that's February 15th is the date
the governor is supposed to have their
budget out as well
uh and it won't be a Saturday right so
so we say onor about the
15th um okay um so that's all I I would
just suggest that you resist every
effort to get it out earlier than when
the governor's budget is
coming because that's when they really
need it we want to make sure that we as
a committee pretty much agree on where
that number should be and um we we've
done fairly well in the past um and
that's because
we've taken our time to listen to the
agencies talk about it figure it out
there's macroeconomic issues uh
Countrywide worldwide there's also State
of New Hampshire issues and we've got to
integrate all those and come up with
what we think the um the revenues are
going to look like
yes we'll also find that we get a set of
preliminary numbers and then as we get
closer to tax day in April the numbers
become more firm
uh because there's some uh preliminary
payments that have been made on some of
the business taxes and such you will
receive a copy of focus which uh gives
some explanation as to where and why the
numbers are that they say that they are
where they are uh I wouldn't pay too
much attention to being uh a bracketed
meaning negative number right now
because you got money coming in later in
the fiscal year and calendar year
oftentimes get confused so keep that
kind of straight in your your
head yes represent Al me yeah I think it
would be useful to take the committee
through or at least the new people
through the revenue
focus and what it does it's it's the it
comes out every month and up to 3 days
after the working days after after the
month is over depending on how
complicated it was and it includes a
description of what is um what that tax
was doing in comparison to the prior
year and in comparison to and and what
it's been doing over the entire year up
to that date and the year starts in July
um and it's oh uh it also includes
things like uh well the insurance money
was just laate it's coming in right
away so don't worry about that part of
it so this kind of thing it' be good I
think to have an introduction for at
least yeah ju so just as a
um the it's being pass around now just
to kind of so you kind of see what it
this is on the
internet you go
to administrative
services financial side I forget maybe
you've got got the exact name of it down
but um and division of Department of
administrative Services the financial
part and um then you look for reports
and you get your choice of this and
on a number of other reports that are in
there including the dedicated funds you
you all should have it um in your email
as well unless you deleted it um we got
it um a few days ago and uh the title on
the email I don't have it in front of me
but it's Revenue Focus December Revenue
it well we'll get one yeah as you said
each month and it it is an indicator of
how things are
tracking um is there anything else
that those of you have been here before
that uh you think we're missing on this
initial talk or are there any
questions if there's nothing if there's
nothing else then as I said the time
frame is around 11:30 I'm having food
delivered so if you want to take a break
can uh do
whatever yes Susan after
weating put your mic on after we finish
eating we've got about an hour so after
we yeah I mean you were just trying to
figure out when to have your caucus you
there may be time after lunch because if
the lunch comes around
11304 to 12 we are not
uh doing anything till 1:00 at 1:00
Society of CPAs will be here so you also
have time so you'll have time between
now and 11:30 and time
1:00 okay but we're eating
together we're eating in in here yes
that the the whole idea being that get
to know each other um and um yeah so
anyways um we'll just uh we'll end it
there for now and
um we'll see when hopefully lunch will
be here around around 11:30
you
e
if members would take their seats we'll
get started
shortly
I
all right the time being uh 5 one we
will get started
with our committee presentation today
we're going to hear from the New
Hampshire Society of uh CPAs and um
Houston good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Robin Houston and I'm the CEO of the New
Hampshire Society of CPAs I would like
to thank all of you for all owing us to
come and give a brief overview of the
accounting profession in our state
offered by some of the most educated and
successful practitioners that are
members of the
society as a brief overview we are a
Statewide nonprofit organization that
works to develop and maintain High
Professional Standards and offers a wide
array of legislative technical support
and networking opportunities to its
members I'm sure you can all appreciate
we're doing a great deal of work with
pipeline high school kids and college
kids to get them interested in coming
into this profession because we need
more accountants so if any of you have
any interest in coming back to the
accounting world please take
note advocacy educational partnership
Partnerships and professional
development are what we strive to
provide and being here today aligns
perfectly with our goal of helping to
understand the complexities with this
field which it has many we also are very
proud of our business Partnerships and
collaborations including that of the new
Hampshire Bankers the New Hampshire bar
the Department of Revenue Administration
and more we have fostered these
relationships and have a wonderful
working partnership with all of them
including quarterly meetings with
commissioner stepp and her
team today you will hear from three of
our esteemed members Joel o CPA partner
k2n CPAs in Windam New Hampshire he was
also a council member at the aicpa and a
former board member and president of the
New Hampshire Society of CPAs Kevin
Kennedy CPA CFE
ABV principal of malonian Kennedy and he
is also on our Board of Directors for
the New Hampshire Society of CPAs as our
tax and legislative committee chair and
also last but not least Corey Reynolds
he's a CPA MST and very recently honored
as a principal at Baker new
minois on your agenda is my contact
information as well as Teresa
Rosenberger who is our legislative
Advocate and helped us schedule to
today's presentation please feel free to
reach out to me directly if I can help
with any followup and I told Jennifer I
would follow over the direct materials
after the presentation today thank you
you so it looks like first up we have
dividends good afternoon chairman and
members we're glad to be here it's
always exciting to come talk about
tax right that's what we
do tax and revenues that's what it's all
about right and I think I feel like what
we've done in the state has been good
partners with the Dr and helping develop
good Tax Administration in the state I'm
proud of all the meetings and all the
things we've done with with the state
and our history I just wanted to have a
quick introduction on uh interest in
dividends I guess the introduction is
last week there was a funeral for it
right I hear so it's it's dead so I
guess there's not a whole lot to talk
about but I would but I would note this
uh and I guess you you all may know
enough about it it was a we all knew it
as a 5% tax on interest and dividends
and then it just kept getting more
complex and more difficult and things to
administer became harder and harder like
um the transferable interest rules that
came up about where certain dividends
from certain llc's were also taxable and
then we had a lot of 754 transactions
where companies were liquidating and
interest and dividends got interesting
for those so I sit back here and look at
it I'm going like I'm even glad that
thing's gone because it just got to be
more and more difficult every year we
went out back in
2014 I was actually appointed by so
that's this is why probably know some of
you by um Governor Lynch at the time to
head a commission on the study of
business taxes and I look at the
document quite a few years ago right 10
years ago and if you look through it
there are things we wanted thought would
make Better Tax Administration and good
things to do and I look at the list and
it's amazing how many of those have been
looked at how many have been changed and
our recommendation even for interest in
dividends tax was to make it simple just
follow what a taxpayer would have on
their schedule B for interest in
dividends and call it a day put whatever
rate you want it but make it much more
simpler to admin administer so I guess I
I sit back and look at if that thing
ever comes back let's call it something
different let's make it easy and uh it
would certainly make a lot more sense
you know you we live in a state where
people don't even think there's an
income tax so as CPA we sit back and
someone comes in and we tell them
they're going to be taxed on interest
and dividends and they go but I moved
here because there's no income tax so
that's the first thing you have to get
over usually with that tax the second
thing and I guess my thought at this
point in time is it used I used to
always think of interest in dividends as
being a even 60 million 70 million maybe
Revenue I think we all know last year
was like
185 but that was a really interesting
Year all of our clients showed up with
these gigantic
interest in dividends uh receipts from
Banks from CDs from their investment
companies and it was a oneoff I most of
my clients already I'll tell you they're
70 75% of what they had for income the
year before so it's not like you can say
we're losing 185 this year maybe it's
down to 150 140 so it was going to go
down anyway so is that enough to say
about interest and dividends we had the
funeral now we can move on
do we have any questions any
questions question Mr chairman represent
do you think changing the word from
interest and dividends tax to
distributions would simplify the message
that this is only under distributions
back to you just something to think
about Mr Al thank you you bet thank you
I hate the word distributions even more
but I I know in talking with uh Lindsay
step she said if if it ever comes back
we're going to call it something totally
different so let's keep all those
thoughts going on what we're going to
call it next time
you well nothing else okay thank you am
I staying up here actually you are
be all right let's talk about bet a
bet you'll hear about in the context of
how it works with B PT so we all know
bet is business Enterprise tax which is
a special tax on special items that a
business has and we'll get a little bit
more definition on on what business
profits are and how it gets taxed but
the two of them certainly work together
and in
1993 I was six years A New Hampshire
resident and that's when all that came
about so it was interesting to find out
about bet and it was so it there was
some thoughts about making business
taxes in New Hampshire a fairer tax
because at the time most um big
companies public companies they had to
leave net income behind there was some
tax they were going to pay because they
had to pay on the profits they had to
keep and we as service people or other
companies uh didn't have to pay any
because all we did was we took all the
money out so we had nothing left behind
that we needed to leave to capitalize
our companies with so it kind of became
a business profits tax on big people
everybody else paid nothing so I
understand that that it came about it
kind of made it a little more
fair and in that twist was something
called the deemed compensation deduction
so for people who were smaller they
could zero out their business profits
tax if they can control it and pay zero
tax and that's where the unfairness came
about be came along and said look we're
going to tax you on three components at
a different rate so if you're a business
you're going to measure your
compensation deductions whether deemed
or actual we're going to add in your
interest expense and we're going to add
in dividends that were paid out and
we're going to add those three and we're
going to tax it at a fairly low rate
today that rate's now 0.55 of 1% so it's
not a big tax but yet it kind of evens
out you know businesses have good years
and bad years and wages are a little bit
more stable so it's been a good
stabilization for for business tax in
New Hampshire that's that's what I my
brain always says Stan Arnold always
used to tell me that so those three
components were important to figure out
your bet the
threshold for that bet tax has continued
to go up it's now at 281,000 so it's a
great tax in that it exempts real small
businesses who shouldn't have to be
paying a
tax that's the positive about where
you're where we're at right
now the the good part about the business
Enterprise tax is it's a credit against
your business profits tax so companies
don't end up paying both they end up
figuring out their business profits tax
their bet and in the end of the day
they're going to pay the highest of the
two but it's it's a formula based on
here's your business profits tax take a
credit for your bet and that's what you
liability uh let's see what else do we
want to talk
about there's been a couple other states
that played around with an Enterprise
tax I think most of them are gone New
Hampshire's probably the only one now
with a business Enterprise tax it makes
New Hampshire a little bit unique and
problematic all at the same time because
you've got a tax that really no other
State plays with so it's U it's more
interesting for new companies coming in
to learn about bet but as I said I think
it's been good in in a way of keeping
State revenues pretty
consistent with within business cycles
that go up and
down there are other credits to
bet there's the research and development
tax credit which can be taken against
bet the New Hampshire children's
scholarship fund there's credits for
funding CTE centers at high schools I
think mostly there's the new family
medical leave
credits there's the insurance tax credit
which a insurance company can take
against their
bet and cdfa credits and a bunch of
others so there's things companies can
tax so just just a real quick and I
might just make this really really quick
let's say a business has 500,000 of
revenues well first of all we know
they're going to be subject to bet but
their but if their business profits is
100,000 they would otherwise have a be a
BPT tax to
pay if
they're if that company is a single
owner and he's left with that 100,000 of
comp left over he's going to pay
$550 to have that $100,000 compensation
under bet assuming his BPT is probably
nothing he's paying 550 for bet so it's
not a bad tax and that's just kind of
the way the formulas work for most small
companies um and I think that's probably
about all I really need to add about
bet unless there's any questions I'd
love to answer them thank you I see a
coup representative Aly
yes um it seems to me that since the PB
the companies that do have to pay the
BPT pay the BET first when we look at
business profits tax what we're looking
at is just the excess above the
BET and so it kind of warps how we're
looking at
things so that's how you your revenue
reports come out from Dr is BET and then
all the additional stuff is the BPT
yeah and I think most companies would
look at bet as their sort of minimum tax
right they're gonna they're never going
that thank you yes represent shamberg Mr
Albright uh what would happen if there
was just a
not two taxes but just a one tax the BET
tax to do away with the BPT you just had
bet do you see a difference in the
amount of Revenue the state would be
getting or be us well I think you would
be right because I think BPT is pretty
well loaded up by large companies that
work in in New Hampshire so you the
interesting question would be maybe to
Dr one of these days is what bet tax
rate would it take to have the same
revenues we're having from both taxes
right now I suspect that's going to be a
pretty
high tax rate if it's 0.55 of a percent
right
now represent Aly thank you if we had
just a
bet um there are quite a few business
businesses with very few employees in
the
state that have um very large
revenue and they they would go Scott
freak
correct or
almost you think they'd pay about the
same I would think they'd pay less I
would think so because bet is kind of a
minimum amount mhm and so you'd lose a
lot of BPT I don't think that would be
good for state
revenues yeah
thanks represent
Erie thank you Mr chair um thank you for
taking my question when you're dealing
with a new company moving into New
Hampshire in a new environment to say
someone who's used to New York or
Massachusetts or places where we're
aggressively recruiting right now when
they see this bet
reaction interesting you know a lot of
them come in because they think a lot of
costs are going to be different and
they're thinking their business tax will
go down and I think that's probably
true the the business profits tax rate
right now is lower than more States than
it was years ago that was part of our
commission report so I think the rat's
gone the right direction I think the
only thing that most people don't like
about bet
is that if they're a startup and they're
they know they've got four years of
losing money they're paying a tax
whereas if they just stayed in New York
and and continued to have business
losses they wouldn't pay anything so the
Bett bet is probably the thing that's
hardest for companies to get over but
then you just talk to about the rate I
mean a rate of less than 1% isn't going
to be a lot of money to fuss about and
that's what I try to get those clients
on thank you for taking my question
represent ORS thank you Mr chair so
thank you for taking my question uh a I
was encouraged by the fact that you
found the tax code
complicated uh having done taxes in the
past and being a former accountant and
Robin I'm not
interested uh is there a way to simplify
some of the tax codes in your mind like
let's just say the i d tax didn't go
away uh how might you uh consider
simplifying it and there there and the
question's been asked really I was going
to ask the similar question is how do we
simplify what we have now between bet
and
BBT thank you yeah and if you if you can
go to the libraries and find our 2014
commission report you'd probably find it
pretty interesting because it's still
it's still pretty accurate today I think
interest in
dividends needed and this is in the
report it needed to be focused just on
those two items and not a world of other
stuff and create an exemption that's
high enough that gets rid of most of the
small
payers and I also think on business
profits and business Enterprise taxes
those thresholds have going up so
they've been sort of helping to keep
small businesses from having to do those
reports and I think those are two of the
greatest things that's happened over the
years with our business taxes I I think
all businesses expect to pay when they
come to New Hampshire and I don't hear a
lot of companies
complaining you know the rates are
lower I think the more that we could
sync our tax code with the IRS code
would be something that would be always
worth
studying because that certainly helps it
thank
yesi I was struck a couple of years ago
when the the man who was head of the Bia
was still head I think it was his last
Terah um he because we were still P sort
of in the pandemic he put together a
remote uh Bia
presentation and he personally
arranged a um interview of three heads
of uh business one of them fairly small
one of them fairly large ones the beer
one in the middle sort of I think um and
after he'd asked them a number of
leading questions they didn't uh say
anything about taxes and so he finally
asked them on what your opinion of our
taxes and two of them said
that I don't know
no uh said we don't know anything about
our taxes the accountant gives it to us
and we sign
it and the third one didn't say
anything so is this
normal yeah I think so because like I
said a minute ago it's the expectation
you're going to pay something and I
think most people understand New
Hampshire is just unique right we're
gonna have our own Solutions we're going
to figure out our own way and I think
most people just understand that when
they come that they're going to pay less
different okay thank you Joel you bet
save some questions for
hello everybody thank you for having me
here today along with the rest of the
group so my task is to talk about the
New Hampshire business profits tax and
somehow squeeze all of that into 10
minutes so we're going to do what we can
we'll touch it at all at a high level
and of course any follow-up questions
we're happy to take them um so the New
Hampshire business profit sax is the
other half of what Joel was talking
about so our two-part tax system for
businesses the business center prise tax
the business profits tax and work hand
in hand as Joel mentioned you get that
credit for those business Enterprise
taxes paid against the business profits
tax and the business profits tax is
really a more traditional income tax so
we're looking at a seven and a half%
rate on the net business uh on the net
profits of the business so really what
I'm going to walk through today so how
do we actually calculate what those net
profits for that business are all right
so we really just start off with well
what what's Federal taxable income
whether that could be the federal
taxable income as a C corporation S
corporation partnership or a sole
proprietorship being picked up on their
personal income tax return is Schedule C
schedule e um and then just due to
differences between New Hampshire tax
law and federal tax law there's a series
of adjustments that end up being made to
arrive at the amount of income that will
be subject to that 75% tax so first what
what I want to touch on and Joel had
talked about this briefly as well is
that New Hampshire compensation
deduction which really applies to
non-corporate entities um so those the
llc's taxes Partnerships General
Partnerships sole
proprietorships um all of those types of
businesses and what this deduction is I
mean I hate to call it a phantom
deduction but you know whether it's
amounts paid out of the business or
deemed amounts to be paid out of the
business it's it's in recognition of the
services provided by the members of that
organization um so when you look at a C
Corp S corporation they're allowed to
take deductions for wages paid to their
service to service providing members so
you know the owner of a C Corp does a
bunch of work for that C Corp they
receive a W2 for their efforts well
that's deductible in arriving at federal
income and at New Hampshire taxable
income the sole proprietor partnership
doesn't have that same write-off so this
is an equalizer and a effect um I think
what really starts to become the fuzzy
math when it comes to New Hampshire is
like well what is that compensation
deduction is in the end that when you
review the rules it it discusses that
it's um a reasonable payment for the
services provided by the member well
what's reasonable when we look it points
to Federal rules related to reasonable
compensation for C corporations which is
extremely broad so in in that regard a
lot many companies can be very
aggressive with those compensation
deductions um within within the letter
of the
law and and I so those taxpayers they
need to be able to um justify that by
with through their own record keeping so
that on an annual basis they should with
you in coordination with their tax
prepare usually determine right well
what is that reasonable compensation
number let's document how we arrived at
that number May it's based on hours
worked maybe it's based on the types of
services provided whatever it might be
um and and then take that deduction on
the return the the flip side is the
option to take a safe harbor uh
compensation deduction which right now
under New Hampshire statute is
$75,000 uh for an entity so if you you
can take that deduction up to 75,000 you
don't have to have to have any
recordkeeping as to how much you took
for that compensation deduction and say
a little bit of legislative history
there as a as a it was the last session
um there was proposals and there's been
proposals in the past as well to raise
that Safe Harbor so that
$75,000 was set well over a decade ago
now with no index for inflation so it's
just been as we know there's certainly
been an inflationary environment the
last few years um believe that proposal
last sum around was to bring that Safe
Harbor deduction it was around1 $110,000
I don't recall the exact amount but then
even further index it for inflation so
they don't run into that same issue on a
go forward basis um so looking beyond
that compensation
deduction
we're we're looking at other adjustments
to ring from federal income down to uh
what's taxable for New Hampshire
business profits um so one of the the
most one of the primary ones that almost
all businesses see is adjustments for
depreciation items and that comes out to
so well in Hampshire says well you
cannot take bonus depreciation like you
can federally and we have a different
number uh maximum amount that you can
expense under Section 179 than you can
for federal purposes so New Hampshire
says all right well you took all those
deductions for federal purposes well you
need to add those back for State of New
Hampshire purposes but then you still
get to depreciate the those items over
their useful life so say something has a
useful life of 5 years when maybe
federally someone was able to write it
off all in year one and New Hampshire
gets written off over five years so by
the time you get to the end of the life
of that asset you've taken the same
deduction for both Federal and New
Hampshire
purposes exactly yeah and that's a very
i' say that's a very common difference
too and you look at across the country
it it is very common that states will
have completely different rules as it as
it goes to bonus depreciation or Section
179 so that's that's a very normal thing
that New Hampshire has um another common
one that I end up seeing with with my
client base is separate entity deduction
which just goes into some of how New
Hampshire addresses Taxation and that is
looking at each LLC each each entity as
a separate entity for New Hampshire
state tax purposes this actually is a
Divergence from how it might be dealt
with at the federal level where you know
they commedy in in my world you great
majority of my clients are in that are
in the real estate space so if you have
someone who has a holding company and
then they have 20 llc's wholly owned by
that holding company so for federally
they just have a single tax return for
State of New Hampshire purposes
potentially they have 20 separate or 21
separate New Hampshire tax returns that
they need to file um but also that
separate entity deduction applies to if
you have flow through you know say that
you have an investment in a partnership
that throws off a K1 well that
partnership might already be subject to
New Hampshire taxation so your next up
level you shouldn't be subject to it
again so again you get to back that out
separate entity so just so each entity
is dealt with in its own Silo for New
Hampshire tax purposes there's combined
filing requirements which can be
triggered which I think Kevin's going to
talk about at least briefly but you know
for someone who's operating wholly in
within the State of New Hampshire that's
a general environment that they're
working in there's a number of other
smaller adjustments that we see uh not
quite as commonly but depends on the
activity of the taxpayer um like
interest income from us obligations
bonds um treasury oh sorry you know
interest and dividend income that was
well subject to the indd tax so that'll
be something that's going away um and
then adjustments related to Federal BAS
adjustments so you know one one person
buys another person's partnership
interest to buy into a partnership well
federally there's a step up in the basis
of the assets for that purchase and they
get to depreciate that step up New
Hampshire has different rules
surrounding that so we won't get into th
those those those complexities but
typically there ends up being a
difference where often times that step
up is not taken for New Hampshire tax
purposes and they don't get that
somewhere depreciation right off uh
going a little bit further down um and
next item on your bullet point list
there's the net operating loss deduction
so this is in recognition it's like all
right well sometimes it doesn't go so
well the business loses money and what
New Hampshire allows is that those
losses can be carried forward up to 10
years and offset uh business profits in
future years any one any annual loss is
limited to 10 million so say someone has
a loss of 12 well they can only carry
forward 10
um
and it's I think the NL is also
something that kind of highlights a
legislative success over the last few
years and what used to be the case for
the NL is it was subject to double
apportionment and this really just
impacted those taxpayers who were doing
business inside and outside of New
Hampshire so they had divide up their
income based on an apportionment formula
um to determine how much of that income
is subject to tax in the state
so the way that the rules worked before
the year that you incurred that loss you
a portioned it based on the current year
percentage and then in the year that you
utilize that loss to offset income it
effectively end up being apportioned a
second time so in that world like say
you had a taxpayer who had a million
dollar loss in year one and a million
dollars of income Year too and let's say
50% of their business occurred in the
state um in both
years so under the old rules once you
end up go going through all of it I'll
save you walking through all the math
but that taxpayer between year one and
year two ends up subject to tax on
$250,000 to the New Hampshire business
profits tax well that's what's that's
the income subject to the tax that's
kind of counterintuitive when you say
wait I made I lost a million I made a
million shouldn't I be a break even well
that's not how the old old rules worked
but that's how they work on a go forward
basis so that was that was a good
win so then once we get through all of
that all right we we've made our
adjustments we've taken out our net
operating losses and then we assess the
tax at 7 and a half% and we aren't quite
done yet because we get to apply all of
our credits um so Joel mentioned a
number of these already the R&D tax
credit is a is a pretty common one
depending on on uh the business clients
are in which is really based on a
portion of the federal R&D credit
expenses that a taxpayer takes uh
education tax credits um Career and
Technical Training tax credits uh cdfa a
lot of these credits are based on a
qualified contributions to specific
programs whether it's a designated
program by you the cdfa Community
Development uh Finance Administration um
or specifically by the state a chosen
project there's a few others out there
that I I don't deal with quite as often
in my world of real estate but the Coos
County credits Paid Family a medical
leave um erz insurance premiums and then
as Joel mentioned those business
Enterprise tax credits which is just a
dollar Ford dooll Credit for anything
you had paid in business Enterprise
taxes and just to further a little bit
of what Joel said when you pay those
business Enterprise tax taxes and say in
a year you didn't have any business
profits tax you were operating at a loss
or your business profits tax was small
enough that your Enterprise tax was
actually larger those excess business
Enterprise tax credits that you weren't
able to use against your BBT carry
forward for up to 10 years so you have
opportunity to use them in a more
profitable
year right so that's all I have on
business profits tax a whirlwind through
it so stop here and see what questions
we may have do we have any questions yes
representative ORS thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question so
you're going through the different taxes
that we pay based on this and that and
tax exemptions so my first thought is
how do we simplify all that and what
what might be the cost savings to the
businesses in the state of New Hampshire
if we were to simplify that tax code
and the piggy back off of that a big
issue that we're hearing of course is
property taxes so years ago uh when I
lived in Pennsylvania the overall State
flat tax and they did have other taxes
was
3.2% so is there a way if you were to uh
put your mind together with Joel and uh
who do we have here Kevin and Robin and
so how do you simplify the tax Cod we
come up with one simple flat tax covers
the property tax covers the school
issues yada yada yada what what what's
the answer in Your Vision to how do we
do that very accounting like answer it
depends lawyer
answer and you know there's a there's a
lot of there'd be a lot of ways to go
about it depending on where you want
that tax base to come from and when I
look at
the the business tax side um and and
that's where most of my client base is
I'd say when we look at the relative
complexity of New Hampshire taxes
compared to the size of the state it's
completely out of balance very complex
yeah exactly it's like we have like when
we have groups that are you know like
large real estate investment groups that
and perhaps are working with a big four
firm they're actually Consulting with
local firms here in New Hampshire
because they don't understand what's
going on with the tax code and they're
trying to understand those
ramifications um as far as making it
simpler it really you know really the
the closer you end up mirroring the
federal side the simpler it gets in my
mind because then there's less of these
adjustments that need to be made on an
annual basis and and and in some ways
you're you're not able to mirror it the
same way with maintaining the same tax
structure we have like you talk about
Partnerships
well at the federal level the income of
the partnership flows through to the
individuals and they pay the tax well
unless we're proposing a a personal
income tax in New Hampshire that's not
going to be the case so you're still
going to be looking with how do you
address those
adjustments at the business level and
across multiple businesses owned by the
same group of owners so it's a it's it's
a very complex it's you still end up in
a complex result to get a simpler answer
if that makes sense
but yeah the closer you end up mirroring
Federal especially a lot of these
adjustments that are made related to
transactions or
depreciation um a lot of those smaller
items if someone can just look at well
here's my federal taxable income that's
what I'm also dealing with with the
state of New Hampshire well inherently
that's simpler um of course it's a
matter of policy as far as well how do
you want to get
there all right
followup thank you Mr chair so you know
God forbid we put the CPA out of
business or the lawyers which we know is
never going to happen but if in in your
opinion if we could simplify the tax
code what would you anticipate a flat
tax being in the state of New
Hampshire I definitely wouldn't be the
one qualified to answer that question
based on the by based on the state
budgets admit that's not something I'm
monitoring so I couldn't give you what
that number might be okay very good
thank you y representa El thank you Mr
chair following up on representative
Wars and and your last point of
discussion here regarding and other
credits yeah if you combine all the
credits Po and then this is a
speculation
question I'm looking for the general
overall rate you said
75% is the base rate we start from what
would be the median or average I know
they're two different things but
somewhere in there rate most businesses
who pay a tax
pay it's really going to depend on the
composition of the B I know terrible
answer um like because when we look at
call like a a a a service organization
that they end up paying entirely the
business Enterprise tax they have an
entirely different world than a
corporate manufacturer that ends up
paying pretty close to that pure 7 and a
half%
rate follow would there be any
methodology which your Association could
come up with that would uh generate some
idea about the differences between uh
say a manufacturing light industrial
versus service and the comparative rates
to make sure that the uh code is
yeah based on the data that the New
Hampshire Dr collects and they have
available to them through the Federal
Tax Returns I'm pretty sure that they
would be able to pull
together something along those lines but
and that that'd be a great question for
Lindsay
too right thank you another followup
please follow up yeah you mentioned uh
that the Safe Harbor is C it's currently
at uh 75k correct I recall some
discussion of increasing that to 100 I
don't remember 110 and I don't remember
uh if that were to take
place that sounds like reasonable but
how would it operate with the cola would
it be an
automatic based upon the federal law or
would we take an action each year to do
it uh I know that if it's if it's a
rolling thing then we're not meeting our
constitutional obligation to the way it
sets According to some people some
people say that it does but how would
that work if you can yeah and from what
I recall from their proposal yeah is I I
couldn't re I think it was a 100 I feel
like I I heard some discussion of a
little bit higher at some point but I
think the proposal was actually 100 um
but the the proposal included a every
other year adjustment for cost of living
increase and I I I don't recall right
now what that was tied to directly you
what metric they were
utilizing thank you represent omy thank
you and way and Ms uh produced that Safe
Harbor bill and we defended it against
Republican opposition and uh got it
through and then uh we're killed in the
election because they used it against us
and then you adopted it but uh and and
you put it up to 75 which is what we
wanted except that uh Governor Lynch was
afraid of going that high so um so it's
been it stayed at
75 um I don't know if it stayed long
enough to get to 100% do you have you
looked at that I mean to 100K yeah C
currently it is just at $75,000 if you
put the CPI which is what we also
remember used for for the BET and the
BPT
um then
um I don't know if it's CPI Urban new H
New England yeah we've beening just off
the cuff my estimation from 75,000 when
that was set over a decade go to to
today just looking at the last few years
I think you'd certainly be well in
excess of 100,000 you'd have to run the
numbers for to be sure but so we'd be
losing a fair amount of
Revenue yeah if it was if was I I'd say
not that high if if the compensation
deduction was increased that Safe Harbor
it could potentially lead
to less Revenue in that now taxpayers
are able to U a safe harbor to have less
subject to business profits tax at 75%
and move it over to the BET bucket at
currently
0.55%
yeah thanks is is that does that end up
being a no questions asked deduction or
is it I know I know you don't have to
have paperwork but is
it can Dr look at and say well this
business that's that's too high for this
or is it no questions asked no they
can't cross the board there there is a
very uh difficult history behind making
it no questions asked let just yeah at
at one point in time there was a number
of Dr audits surrounding reasonable
compensation that has not been the case
for some time in my experience okay
great thank you um seeing no other
and let's see it looks like we now have
up good afternoon Mr chairman members
of uh of the commission uh I will add to
my resume that Robin gave that some time
ago I participated in a legislative
committee on um Water's Edge versus
worldwide reporting a couple of folks
are here on this committee now that we
we serve together on that um so so far
we've been discussing uh New Hampshire
taxation I'm going to take it a little
bit further in some of the other complex
areas as it relates to when you have a
business entity that has activity in
more than one state and so the
considerations that these entities have
to take on is um where might they have a
filing requirement in what states and if
they do once they figure out they have
to file in more than one state how do
they split up the pie how do they take
that net income and piece it to the
various States in order to determine
what their taxable income is and their
taxes are in in those
States further than that if you have
entities that have some commonality
common control common operations and and
relationships is there a requirement
that these entities have to combine
their reporting into one reporting to
the state of New Hampshire or other
states
and then lastly I'm going to touch base
on if you have a New Hampshire entity or
taxpayer that may have an interest in a
foreign entity and how does that
activity get reported in New Hampshire
so relative to the first item as to
whether or not there's a filing
requirement and many of you we have sat
through this presentation before and and
so hopefully this is just a refresher
but one of the magic words that we use
is Nexus and Nexus uh kind of loosely
defined uh is the requisite contact
between a taxpayer and a state before
the state has jurisdiction to tax uh the
taxpayer meaning does the taxpayer have
some presence within a state that the
state laws and the federal laws
potentially mean that they're now
subject to the taxation rules and laws
of that particular State now when
there's a physical presence for a
company they have employees in a state
they have property in a state they have
an office that will almost automatically
create Nexus to make them subject to the
taxation laws and rs of that particular
state but a lot of states have um Nexus
definitions that go beyond just a
physical presence we often refer to
these as economic Nexus excuse me I'm
want to check my clock because I tend to
ramble i' love to hear the sound of my
own
voice um New Hampshire has a definition
under um RSA
77a uh and I won't read all of it but it
refers to a business activity business
activity means a substantial economic
presence evidenced by a purposeful
direction of business toward the state
etc etc and so in New Hampshire it's not
just physical Nexus but potentially an
economic Nexus could create now one
hurdle that states have to face with
economic Nexus is public law 86 272
which has been around a long time and
that essentially uh limits the ability
for a state to impose taxation
if the only activity a company has in a
state is the solicitation of orders but
that has come through a lot of
challenges over the last few years you
may be familiar with South Dakota versus
Wayfair in which there was an decision
by the courts that for sales and use tax
they don't need physical presence they
just need economic presence and every
state comes up with their own definition
of economic presence and so now States
outside of New Hampshire because we
don't have a sales tax can require
companies that do business out of the
state to collect and remit sales tax to
those States even though they physically
don't go into the state and they only
have maybe a connection in terms of
using um thirdparty Freight shifters to
move their product there um also more
recently the um Public Law 86 272 in
terms of this limitation um has been
challenged in terms of that it's only
tangible property that is subject to
this law not services and intangible
properties so services like that of an
attorney or CPA that may extend into
another state may be subject to these
economic Nexus and so that's the first
thing a a a company has to do is do I
get do I have Nexus whether it's
physical or economic that may make me
subject to the taxation laws of another
state so once they make that decision
that they have a filing requirement the
next thing is um how do we split up the
p and that's where this next term
apportionment which has already been
used here comes into play and a portion
meant roughly is essentially the formula
that the states develop to determine how
you allocate your net profit to the
various states that you're taxable in
historically there used to be three
things that states used to look at
including New Hampshire sales property
and wages um a couple years ago uh New
Hampshire moved to just looking at sales
that we refer to it as the single sales
Factor so New Hampshire when looking at
a portion M formula only looks at sales
a lot of other states have moved over to
sales as well but even though that has
been simplified to only include sales
there's still a lot of um ambiguity or
complications that come with just
looking at sales apportionment um and
part of that is really because it's hard
to because states have some States
including New Hampshire recently have
moved to market-based sourcing so
historically we used to use and some
states still use cost performance I'm a
CPA I do a tax return for a client who
uh lives in Massachusetts but all my
employees are here so under cost of
performance that sale was generated here
in New Hampshire because that's where we
the cost of that performance was
incurred under the market based approach
because the client is in Massachusetts
and they receive the benefit of my
service in Massachusetts that sale is
now a portioned to Massachusetts for
purposes of determining how we allocate
it for the two tax returns that I file
in New Hampshire and Massachusetts so
that's market-based sourcing and again a
couple years ago New Hampshire moved to
market-based sourcing it gets very
complex uh for a number of reasons you
know you take a software company that
develops software in one state but they
put it on a server in another state for
a client that has places all over the US
that access it or maybe download it and
how do you determine what the state is
and so there's a lot of complexity that
comes with market-based
sourcing um but so now we've moved from
uh Nexus and now we've determined how do
we split the pi the apportionment and
then we come into the question is what
if you have a lot of businesses that
have common relationships and there are
reasons in which they've kind of
segregated these operations into
separate companies well this is where we
get into the concept of unitary filing
um uh unitary filing the definition uh
is located also under RSA 77a it says
unitary business business means one or
more related business organizations
engage in business activity both within
and without the state among which there
exists Unity of ownership operation use
and interdependence in their functions
so if there's some ownership or
commonality or use between these
entities and they may be determined that
hey you got to take these separate
entities and you have to combine them in
order to report so you would put these
entities together into one profit and
loss and balance sheet you might SE take
out inter company um activity and then
you'd apportion it again based on the
apportionment rules and you come up with
one return for one or several entities
um uh to report in New Hampshire um
under Revenue ruling section 301 they
get into more detail the definition of
unity of operation uh use Etc
so we now have a situation where we have
this complexity of multiple States and
potentially consolidating entities
together and some states states have
unitary requirements that have different
definitions than what New Hampshire has
and some doesn't and so for as a
practitioner I may find that I have to
fill a unitary return for New Hampshire
but file several returns for my clients
um in different states that are
individually done um so that is the
concept of uh unitary filing uh and the
last item is relative to um when we have
foreign activity and as I had mentioned
I was on that commission about worldwide
reporting and Water's Edge so when we
talk about uh
apportionment New Hampshire uses what's
known as a waters's edge and essentially
The Waters Edge means go up to the coast
and you're done you don't include any
other entities in your unitary filing
that are outside of the United States
historically New Hampshire would only
tax the income on foreign entities when
the money came into the state so you
have an entity in New Hampshire they own
a company in Germany Germany issues a
distribution it comes back to the US and
then New Hampshire would tax it at that
particular point a couple of budget
sessions ago I'm sorry in uh the tax cut
and jobs act which was a major overhaul
of the federal system back in 2017 came
up with a new tax for foreign companies
it's called the guilty tax Global
intangible low tax income and
essentially this uh federal government
is now looking at foreign entities that
are controll foreign corporations and
including that income onto the federal
return is a credit for foreign taxes but
um and a couple of budget sessions ago
it was decided that 50% of This Global
intangible low tax income would find its
way onto the business profits tax return
and so there is some inclusion of global
intangible low tax income on the New
Hampshire business profits tax return so
even though we are still at Water's Edge
meaning we're not incorporating all of
those foreign entities onto the New
Hampshire return um there is recognition
of foreign income to a degree on the New
Hampshire return so
um I think that's about my 10 minutes
and I know that's a lot and if your head
didn't hurt a little bit after I'm done
then I didn't do my job right so thank
you representative shamberg thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh is there a
possibility of reduction of uh net
profits to be taxed by the state of New
Hampshire if you use only single sales
or if you only use market-based sour ing
I don't have the data to understand I
think the Dr would would would have a
better sense of that yeah I just thought
would represent boards thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so back in the covid when
people were working in New Hampshire but
still had to pay a mass tax they weren't
Computing the max a mass uh how does
that play into your economic your Nexus
and your uh you know can you give us how
that played out sure so relative to what
I was referring to which has to do with
the the business activity um it it
didn't play into it quite as much and
and I and I can expand on that if need
be but I think what you're referring to
is individuals who were employees of
companies in Massachusetts and they
weren't in Massachusetts working but
Massachusetts was still taxing it yeah
so and by the way I think that mass
pulled that off but that's a significant
issue in terms of other states too New
York is very aggressive that if you work
for a New York company even though you
never step state in Step into the state
they're still taxing you as a New York
employee um and so essentially the um uh
the states basically especially when Co
hits pass these laws that said look we
know that the the rules used to be if
you weren't in the state it wasn't
considered Mass wages um but of course
when Co hit they said no we we can't
just suddenly lose all this Revenue
because everybody's working at home um
I'm not sure I've seen too much there's
been a lot of discussion and debate and
I'm not sure what court cases have come
up on this but it seems to me that the
states have largely won on their um
arguments that if you're working for a
company in their state and there's some
sort of connection enough within that
state that you're in it or that you um
um uh um don't have an exemption that
those taxes are subject to income taxes
personally for those States so probably
not a great answer to your question but
no pretty much so was New Hampshire
follow up thank you so was New Hampshire
able to uh maybe buffer that a little
bit
or um I I don't think so I I know there
there were some efforts I think by the
state a couple years ago when that
happened to kind of repudiate that and I
don't think it ever got it my
recollection is it didn't get anywhere
represent elme yes could I ask on in a
case like that if someone is living in
Connecticut and working in in New York
City remotely only uh would he end up
paying income tax in both
States potentially the same so on on the
Assumption he would be subject to New
York taxes now New York does have
exemptions for things like if you are if
your employer requires it and um if
you're kind of the office for that
employer in in in that state um if
you're subject to it then every state is
a little different relative to how they
don't double tax you so for instance in
Connecticut I think us the example I
think they would give you a tax credit
for the taxes that you paid in New York
so you'd figure out your Connecticut
taxes and say this is the total amount
if um if I had to pay it all to
Connecticut but we'll give you a little
some some amount of credit for the taxes
you paid in New York so if the New York
rate is higher maybe you'd get a full
credit or some percentage every state is
different so I don't know what
Connecticut would do in this particular
case but a lot of states do provide a a
credit to taxes you pay to other state
on that income that you're reporting in
that
state representative
opal thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question I I'm I I want to
go back to uh market-based sourcing and
I'm going to simplify this please do
well I'm going to try let see if see if
my simplification works if I understood
your explanation it sounds like it is
the difference
between uh taxing where the work
occurred as opposed to taxing where the
result of that work is enjoyed yeah yeah
every state again defines a little
differently but it's largely who
received the benefit of that and
sometimes determining who receives the
benefit could be is a complex issue okay
follow up Mr chair
um I'm I'm trying to understand you you
said uh New Hampshire adopted the
market-based sourcing
yes it it sounds to me
like that would be
detrimental to revenue
potentially um in the example you cited
you know in your own your own firm if
you're doing the work under the old
system the Hampshire would have taxed
you for for whatever profit you made on
that in the in Market based
sourcing um Massachusetts presumably
would would tax it and and New Hampshire
wouldn't get the
benefit if that's
correct what was the justification
because the same CPA in Massachusetts
doing for doing uh work for somebody in
New Hampshire now has to pay portion
that income to New Hampshire and so the
it was largely done to capture I I
shouldn't I'm spe speculating a little
but my opinion is that it was largely
done to capture revenue for outof State
companies that had customers here in New
Hampshire but weren't really because the
work was being done out of the state
that weren't really paying a a level of
Taxation in New Hampshire and I know I
have um contact I've had discussions
with the Dr and commissioner step and
I've asked them have they been able to
evaluate that and I think the answer was
no they didn't have enough data yet to
determine both single sales and Market
based sourcing what the ramifications
are in the revenue but I don't
anticipate that there has been a huge
swing one way or the other by moving to
those one one last how how long ago was
that change made and I'm hoping Dr is
actually trying to capture both were
fairly recent um single sales uh was for
periods after December 31st 22 so only a
couple of years ago and uh market-based
before and I have um tax appearance
after for December 31st 21 uh was we
moved to Market based sourcing thank
you any other
questions okay seeing none thank you
very much thank you chairman uh members
of the commission thank you thank you to
all the uh CPAs that came today and we
okay that pretty much concludes uh the
agenda I had prepared for today um our
next meeting as I mentioned earlier
would be Monday January 13th and uh we
have a meeting Tuesday the 14th as well
both starting at 9:00 we'll hear from
agencies state agencies on the 13th and
some outside agencies on the 14th what
we really want to start understanding is
what is the you know where are revenues
what's the direction of revenues heading
because as I said earlier we'll be taxed
with coming up with the uh Revenue
estimates that pretty much determine
what the state can can uh pay or or use
Finance can use over the next two years
so it's a very important uh job that
this committee has and um that'll be the
start uh next week any questions before
we before we
adjourn all right all right thank you
later